this in fact is our new American moment
there has never been a better time to
start living the American dream so to
every citizen watching at home tonight
no matter where you've been or where
you've come from this is your time if
you work hard if you believe in yourself
if you believe in America then you can
dream anything you can be anything and
together we can achieve absolutely
anything alright that was the president
earlier tonight here with reaction to
this an important moment is Homeland
Security Secretary Kirsten Nielsen let's
talk specifically about the immigration
proposals give us some detail sure so I
think that the president laid out is a
very clear vision for how to increase
security on our borders while also
revising immigration and part of the
borders is you know Shaun is not just
infrastructure but it's the technology
it's the personnel and it's closing the
loopholes so that we can detain and
remove those who come here illegally I
think the president was clear he asked
for bipartisan support and it was really
a unifying moment I think on some
important issues secretary I've been
down to the border a dozen times I've
been from the Rio Grande of San Diego
I've seen drug warehouses I've seen gang
members I've been in helicopters boats
altering vehicle you can laugh at me on
horseback I've seen all of this and we
always end up getting the the
consideration the amnesty going back to
86 we never ever get the wall funded and
built is this going to be different this
time well the president insists on the
money that he controls to build the
border before any deal
we have to have the wall we have to have
the wall walls work we've seen it in the
folding it in San Diego and the funding
the funding he's been clear so in the
proposal he offered last week it's a 25
billion dollar fund which will include
not only that infrastructure but
technology for the southern and the
northern border as well as some of the
personnel cost and access roads that we
need but yes I think he's made it very
clear this is a priority our border is
you know Shawn is more secure than it
has been in the past however the numbers
continue to increase behind a 300%
increase in unaccompanied minors in the
last six months we also had a six
hundred percent increase in family units
so when we talk president talked a lot
about gangs tonight so I think it's time
to do it he's he's very committed I'm
committed I'll work with anyone and
everyone he will talk to me about this
Matt Madam Secretary I've seen it all
firsthand and I think it is definitely
in terms of national security one of our
if not the number one priority we have I
suspect when Chuck Schumer pulled his
offer off the table and then listening
to other Democrats it sounds to me
politically they don't want to deal they
don't want daca they want to run on daca
in 2018 so for all the sanctimony I
suspect politically they have very
different motives and then you've got
liberal Republicans like Lindsey Graham
and and senator snowflake I'm sorry Jeff
Flake I call them snowflake out in
Arizona that it seems like they're just
want amnesty well in a shot it's
disappointing because as you know
Senator Schumer voted for the wall many
of our Democratic colleagues have voted
for the wall so this is politics and I
think what you heard from the president
tonight is enough of that
it was a unifying message it was a call
across the aisle it was a croc call
across
houses of Congress and it was a call to
action it's time to do it we need to
increase the security for our
communities and it's time to reform an
immigration system that's on autopilot
and does not in any way help improve our
economy
do you suspect as I do that there's
politics being played by the Democrats
in other words I question their
sincerity and whether or not they want
this deal because the press the
president said tonight this is a
compromise deal this is okay you get
what you want and we'll get what we ran
on no I think it is a compromise he
listened to members from both parties as
did I and all I can tell you with
respect to that is we're committed we're
negotiating good faith I've been on the
hill many many times over the past few
weeks I've talked to hundreds of members
of Congress I'll continue to do that
I've been to the border myself talk to
the state and local officials down there
as well as landowners and Americans who
live there and see the threat coming
across the border
so we're negotiating good faith will
continue to do that I hope that they
will agree to do the same all right
Madam Secretary good to see you thank
you for joining us tonight we appreciate
it